when you walked out I was like you look
like an action figure
hey there I'm aria and for four months
this year I trained in MMA before
actually stepping in a cage and fighting
someone what a fun time that was if you
haven't seen that video I would
encourage that you check it out because
the rest of this video will probably
have a lot of spoilers spoiler alert
today I want to break down how things
actually happen over the course of the
17 weeks talking about my training my
diet the fight itself as well as
answering a few questions that you guys
had in the comments so originally I was
only going to train for three months but
then that got postponed to four months
because of a scheduling change with the
promotion I was fighting for
but either way three or four months was
always gonna be a tight time for him to
try and get this done
so I to make sure my training was just
as good as it could be and luckily I put
together a great team to work with
I had Steve Zim of a tide of you fitness
studio working on my strength and
conditioning and then I also had Chris
Riley who is a former Moya Thai and
kickboxing champion as my head coach as
well as Daniel Gutierrez over at Defiant
gym as my striking coach so with Steve
Chris and Daniel I had a crack team
working with me to make sure I was at
least going to be as fight ready as
possible within three to four months the
die was also very very key because I was
aiming to fight a featherweight which
means I had to weigh in on fight day at
145 pounds
we were 154 and and so that came down to
my work with trifecta nutrition I worked
with Emmy and Mario over there their to
the team and the priority of the diet
was clean eating no processed sugar and
making sure I just hit my macros while
staying under 19 hundred calories and
within that window my macro breakdown
was 70 grams of fat 150 grams of protein
and 215 grams of carbs by the end of my
training period though my caloric limit
and my americo's have changed and so I
was at 2300 calories maximum 75 grams of
fat 150 grams of protein at 250 grams of
carbohydrates I was so strict with my
diet I would log everything I had on my
trifecta app I had a food scale at home
and at work
that I would take to restaurants with me
to make sure I was weighing my food
properly some may say that was a little
overkill but I just want to make sure I
was doing it right
so one of the first things we did was
that we went to go get my body fast scan
together we are at body spec to get a
DEXA scan this is the most accurate way
to get a body fat reading because you're
getting a direct reading from head to
tell which is why the number is
significantly higher per my total body
photos 28.4% a lot higher than jack and
i thought before we even began the
entire filming process you actually took
me on whom i'll run to see where I was
at cardio-wise yeah we did the run and I
was pretty surprised with how bad your
running was good so it's Steve zimwi
work not just on strength training but
making sure that my cardio was on point
we would work on machines like Jacob's
Ladder this is the hardest cardio ever
because not only are you using your legs
but you're using your arms your arms are
going up above your heart so when your
arms are up here your heart rate goes up
even higher jack basically did train
with me three days a week in the
mornings with Steve Steve is an
incredible trainer this isn't just a
transformation for what we're doing here
you're gonna be able to take this to
other parts of your life
he showed us things that I've never seen
before I've never done I came up with
this years and years ago
we do a bungee cord
so normally when you bench press when
you at the bottom it's the hardest we
get to the top it's easiest but when
you're in sport were your body shape you
want that extension to be the most
explosive so we make the bottom the
easiest and then top the hardest it was
like a lot of weight lifting but very
technical he would also isolate things
you'd be doing leg curls with one leg
here have you hold one of the handles
here and one of the handles here and do
those punches I've never seen that
before
we built it up and we built it up and
every time I added more and more to him
he could do it he was shocking me every
time because I thought okay he's not
gonna be able to bench this he does it
he's not gonna be able to shoulder press
this he does it he can't hold this
position for 30 seconds he does it and
so that lets me keep pushing and pushing
and pushing keep in mind actually just
got this test done today and so this is
after a couple weeks at eating but I
dropped 10% at least a body fat in these
four months of training that's great I
did not know exactly how cut I was going
to be able to get him but he looks
amazing I'm very humbled to have had the
experience to learn more Thai from a
champion fighter like Chris Riley I can
do this and sure like you know a big
strong guy can probably create some
power right well watch this we did a
crash course in muy Thai Chris had to
throw so many fundamentals at me that it
was hard to sort of juggle all of them
at once there's so much coordination
required you know my body's just not
used to moving in the ways I expected I
mean turn your body
bang-bang and now come up bang I was
trying to absorb so much in such a
limited amount of time that it was tough
at first when Daniel of define gym like
Chris and I trained at his gym however
that was a huge plus because essentially
I was training with Chris but then I was
also able to train during classes at
define as well to further hone my skills
and at that point it was more a matter
of just repetition one two one kick
beautiful better a question we did
receive a lot was about how much
grappling I actually did so I did take
some jujitsu classes at the
Jim and Chris actually had some jujitsu
training himself so he was able to coach
me but we definitely didn't do as much
grappling or ground work as I would have
liked because obviously grappling is
such a huge part of MMA but there's only
so much I could learn in such a short
amount of time so if I do fight again I
would definitely add a lot more
grappling training into my work and so
if there are any wrestling or Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu coaches out there that want to
train me slide into my DMS there were a
lot of doubts like after getting beat up
I would wonder why am i doing this to
myself you know I might actually cut out
for this and so these doubts plagued me
a lot and I think in every single
sparring session I was always the guy
with the least amount of experience so I
was just getting my ass handed to me
each time then a guy knew you when
you're in a while he needs you right in
the stomach and you're like but then you
got back up and think mentally Ari is
very strong physically I don't know he's
probably one of the softest people I
know I like to say I'm a really
optimistic person but I'm also a realist
and if I'm being real
I'm scared we care about you so much I
don't think what everyone said came from
a place of like them trying to doubt you
it was just from a place of protection
and defense and they were scared I just
want to hold him and keep any harm from
coming to him I never want to seem in a
situation where someone would hurt him
everyone envisions themselves in you and
kind of like gets scared because they're
like I would never do that because
they're afraid to fail everyone's afraid
to fail and you're not and that's very
rare you came to the fight and we only
recently got close
true but you for some reason we're one
of the very few people that believe in
me go figure
I was watching you train in like the
week that we had started chatting and
you were measuring out your food which
was bizarre and you were really not
making meetings because you were going
to train and I could just kind of gather
that you were taking this very very very
seriously so I had no doubt that you
were
gonna be as prepared as you possibly
could in the beginning I was like
there's no way that he sticks with this
diet and exercise schedule but he's
really done it
he's been so diligent like it's almost
scary it is scary biggest low point for
you I feel like was when you found out
the fight was pushed
got a call from the promotion and
they're they're pushing back the fight
date I was concerned because I already
put my body through something I had
never done before so the idea of another
month of hard training of dieting it was
a struggle really hard I can tell you
that a breaking point I think with us at
a time but just let the door open for
more doubt to just get in my head but I
think what helped me overcome everything
was just talking to my coaches never
once in the journey that they ever
really seemed to doubt me and I knew I
owed it to them and to myself to just
power through packing up the car right
now because today is fight day weigh-ins
in the morning was my first time ever
seeing casein and meeting and face to
face
and the resonators kind of spent myself
mentally ready you're doing something
that a lot of men these days don't have
the balls to do so no matter what when
you walk out of there you better walk
out of there with your head up high but
no matter what you better walk in there
and destroy this mother you know now is
about doing it it's just about doing it
yeah originally you were not coming to
the fight I will not be seeing it I
don't want to see it I don't want to see
the fight but you came to the fight in
the end REO we love you so much and you
are so inspiring because you really put
yourself into your work for a reason for
a Cause and for love and I hope that you
fight tonight for love I think I was
like yeah he's got this Arya's got this
until I saw one of the guys get his
shoulder dislocated and they tried to
like pop it back in oh and I know you
guys knew backstage would you didn't
tell him you guys knew I have never been
more out of my element
I don't think then when I walked into
that arena I got to a point before your
fight where I was like why am I here I
don't know this guy that well like I
really this is just like the last thing
I want to be doing right now I'm
watching a man screaming pain really
close now distractions man like a whole
of it you go in the back everyone else
too like don't yet the focus like stay
really focused on the most nerves I had
was that moment before I made my walk
out right now I was no joke
yeah this is a real thing yeah now it's
not a dream now it's not a concept now
it's real the more my name was announced
it all just went away and I just knew it
was time oh when you walked out I was
like you look like an action figure
you were like angry no smile chiseled
pissed I was like 2d contour because
your cheekbones like popping off and you
march down and I seriously thought
you're gonna kill someone I was like
artists brought us all here today to
possibly murder this man I felt good
when if I began you looked good you
looked like you were doing something
right you were in it you were fighting I
could see you were like calculated and
everything but then I think honestly it
was just a lack of experience case they
put me into a guillotine and then I was
like hmm he's gonna he's gonna get out
of this and then it was like a couple
seconds later I'm like huh
okay he's still fighting through it yeah
punch him punch him
I remember Jason squeezing his arms I
remember feeling my neck getting crushed
but I do also remember thinking myself
whatever you do don't tap out I'm not
going to tap out of this guy and then
when your arm dropped your body dropped
like that like a rag doll I was like is
he dead okay the mood dropped like
everybody froze and nobody made eye
contact and everybody was like craning
to try to look at you I think I I like
kind of blacked out like I don't even
know if my footage was usable or
anything from the ring so it's just so
like what just happened even then you
were right back up again and we're like
oh I feel like you were almost as much
of a daze as I was that's why I felt bad
but the lawsuit except I didn't wanna
let you down
don't feel bad you did a incredible job
and like you did so much and you
accomplished things that most people
couldn't do
one time you did good good you just got
a yeah dude I trained for four months
for one minute
but that's fighting right that's that's
the game that's the sport and I have no
ill feelings about that that's that's
what I signed up for someone has to win
someone has to lose good sup man no one
can do that what have been great for the
fight to go all three rounds yeah
whenever been great for me to win yeah
and do I think I could have won yeah I
think I actually felt good in there but
that's fighting twice as long one of the
biggest questions I've received is if I
actually will fight again and if I've
been completely honest yeah I would love
to fight again the question is when I
would fight again
this sport takes so much time so much
dedication that if I were to do it again
I would want to do it right I wouldn't
want a half-ass it
are you surprised when I say that I
would want to fight again no I want you
to do it I want you to fight again I had
the only reason I will go back into
another casino like that is if you fight
again just don't get choked out again
please
but regardless of whether or not I fight
again this this has truly been probably
the greatest experience in my life so
much of the fight game and life is it's
all in our heads you know it's it's our
fears it's our doubts but it's us trying
to control those fears and doubts and
allowing them to motivate us instead of
hinder us that's where success can be
found I'm very grateful to everyone
that's been a part of this journey
including all of you that took the time
to watch I hope that all of us can take
away from my experience the endless
possibilities that are within each of us
[Music]